- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understand of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are, and
how we got here; an exploration made
possible by the generosity of humans like
you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Anne] So I wanted to say just a couple
of things about today's talks, which I
think you'll all agree were fantastic and
very interesting. Yes. Hopefully I'm not
as...when I think back about all that's
really happened and developed in the field
of ancient DNA, it's really quite amazing.
And you know, I'm older than I hopefully
look, but when I was a graduate student in
1990, I actually started working on
ancient DNA and this very new field of
ancient DNA. There were only a handful of
papers that were published. And I talked
to my adviser and got him to agree that I
could give this a try and I started doing
some preliminary work with this brand new
technology called PCR, right, and it was
great, and I managed to work really hard,
and I got a few bands, and I did these
analyses and saved them on my five and a
half inch floppy. And my adviser, it was
very laborious let me tell you, my adviser
said, "There's this new conference,
international conference on ancient DNA.
Why don't you go to that and talk about
what you've done?" And so, I printed out
my paper on the dot matrix and off I went
to Nottingham, England, and there were
really only 30 or 40 of us there. It
included Svante Paabo, Erika Hagelberg,
and Dan Bradley, who's done some amazing
work on domestication of cattle. And I
don't think any of us there thought that
now we would be looking at these genome
sequences from archaic humans. I think
that was really beyond the pale because if
you think back, those of you who were even
alive, some of you were I know. That was a
time when the human genome project was
just beginning and these technological
advances have both in terms of just the
sequencing technology, but also the
computational biology necessary to analyze
these data have just...it's been really
astounding. And with the Neanderthal
genome project these ancient DNA methods
were really pushed farther and like
Matthias Meyer, I'm very excited to see
what comes next. You know, also in the
early 90s, we were in the out of Africa
versus multi-regionalism debate and I
think we now are, it's obvious from
today's talks that we're in the mostly out
of Africa, look at all these interactions
and admixture events that have happened
and it's really quite fascinating. Another
thing that I would point out is the
analysis of the modern human genomes is
imperative for understanding the context
and seeing these patterns of local
adaptation and then now with the ancient
data of seeing how they develop through
time. I think Johannes' talk was really
lovely in giving us that really fine grain
sense of population history in Europe. And
we're beginning to also see that to some
extent in the Americas. I think it's also
fascinating to think that the archaic
human cousins are still with us, in a
sense. In that we have these pieces of DNA
that give us a really fascinating insight
into what they have given us, and also
into what they haven't given us. I think
is also quite fascinating. And so, now I
think perhaps we are ready for some
questions. All right, so I'm going to turn
it over to Ed for the first 20 minutes of
questions.
- [Ed] Thank you. Anne, you have your work
cut out for you too there are a bunch of
questions for the second half. I have
picked out a few of the many fantastic--
we have a question over here if someone
wants to get that-- questions that were
submitted via these cards, so speakers
from the first part, on your toes. So the
first one comes for Sriram, and the
question is "Did we inherit diabetes
strictly from the Neanderthals?" And I
would like to embellish this question a
little bit. Is there any particular single
thing that we can say, "We got that from
Neanderthals?"
- [Sriram] Yeah, I think this was also
pointed out in Tony's talk, which is for
most phenotypes that we care about, they
are what we call complex phenotypes which
means they are influenced my a multitude
of genes, each of which has a small
effect, coupled with the environment. So
given that one of these genes, or a few of
them came in from the Neanderthals doesn't
really tell us that Neanderthals gave
us...are the reason why we have increased
risk for type 2 diabetes. So they do
moderate the risk, to a small extent, but
by no means are they the single dominant
reason why we have type 2 diabetes, or for
that matter, any other complex phenotype.
I think we have yet to find a good example
of a phenotype where Neanderthals gave us
"the" gene for the trait of interest.
- Thank you. So the next question is for
Brenna, and this is concerning the much
older Y chromosome that was found in
current populations in West Africa. That
was a bit of a stunning thing that this Y
chromosome tree we thought we knew
forever, then, I think, initially was
found in someone in South Carolina, then
later West African population. “How does
this influence how we interpret African
population history?”
- [Brenna] That's a great question. Sorry,
that's a great question. Yes, there have
been initially this one very divergent Y
chromosome that was found in an African
American individual and coalesces much
deeper in the tree than the Y chromosome
phylogeny that I presented, approximately
200,000 years ago. And I personally think
that this is probably the best evidence we
actually have for archaic intergression
within contemporary African populations. I
would like to point out that it's
basically only been found in a handful of
individuals, so it doesn't really explain
the vast majority of Y chromosome
variation that you see in Africa, which is
really more representative of the tree
that I put up, but it's certainly
suggestive of archaic intergression.
- Great. So the next series of questions
here, kind of on the theme for Christina
Warner. First one, “How is the use of
mouthwashes seriously effected our
microbiome, has that happened.” So a very
kind of contemporary thing, and then a
similar question. “What about cooking? Do
we see anything in the record of dental
calculus to reflect any kind of changes
that might have happened around cooking
our food?”
- [Christina] So these are great
questions. I can leave you assured that
mouthwash actually does absolutely nothing
except give you fresh breath for a brief
period of time. So it doesn't appear to
really alter, in any persistent way, your
microbiome. What probably is having a much
more intense effect, is toothbrushing,
obviously you're constantly removing the
plaque from your teeth. And as a result,
one thing that I've noticed, and in
combination with modern dentrifices, or
toothpastes, that are tarter control
toothpastes, they actually slowly dissolve
the tarter on your teeth, and that does
seem to actually shift your microbiome. As
I showed you those layers that form on
teeth, they are actually microbially
structured. The first bacteria that can
attach to teeth are called early
colonizers. They're primarily
Streptococcus and Actinomyces and then
other bacteria build on them, and if
you're a really aggressive tooth brusher,
you keep scrapping off all that plaque,
and so you constantly have early
colonizers and you don't get the late
colonizers that form. It's actually really
good for your health because the
periodontal pathogens are late colonizers,
so toothbrushing is highly effective and
does change your oral microbiome but
mouthwash does not. That's a long answer
to a short question. And the second
question was about cooking. That's
actually a fantastic question and it's one
that I'd really like to investigate myself
and I haven't made much progress in that
direction. I can say, though, that some
really interesting work, done by Amanda
Henry at the Max Planck, she actually
works on starch granules, similar to the
ones that I showed and she has been
looking at whether or not she can identify
cooked starch versus uncooked starch by
looking at some of those. And there are
some changes that occur to starch during
cooking that might indicate the
introduction of cooking. That then we
could potentially triangulate with oral
microbial changes but we aren't quite
there yet but I think it's actually a
great question.
- Thank you. One for Matthias Meyer.
Someone very impatiently asks, "Why is it
taking so long to date Homo naledi and has
its DNA been sequenced?” So I will put
that to you and broaden the question a
little bit. This field has been, since the
beginning, kind of driven by technology.
For this sample, or any other samples, are
there any great technologies that you can
imagine on the horizon that might be the
thing that we, in five years, look back on
and say, "Yeah, that really sparked the
next revolution."
- [Matthias] I mean, regarding the Homo
naledi, I think that is a question for the
rising star expedition team. I think it's
a very sort of complex site to date for
geological methods. I think the stuff sort
of lies on the ground, basically there's
nothing on top of it, it's probably going
to be very difficult. There are no sort of
DNA results from this as far as I know,
but who knows if that would ever come.
Generally, I think there's still room for
improvements in ancient DNA research, for
example, my group we're also working on
DNA repair attempts. That has been done in
the past, but I have some reason to
believe we would do better now. Yeah, I
think it's too early to give up, right, so
yeah, I think there will be more things
coming.
- Great. Next question for Kay. Someone
wants to know, “Could the extinction of
Neanderthals be related to the inbreeding
that you showed?''
- [Kay] That's a good question. So, I
can't really answer this really.
Inbreeding itself is not necessarily
deleterious, right. So you can have lab
mice that are inbred, for instance, and
they are living very happily in their
cages. So inbreeding itself is certainly
not necessarily a reason that a group of
humans must go extinct. So that's for
sure. But of course, if you see a decline
in the size of the population, then you
can kind of say, "Okay, this might be
caused by something." And what this
"something" is we don't really know. So it
could be pathogens, or it could be just
harsh living conditions or just changes in
environment. And I really have to say that
there are many different papers that have
actually tried to answer what made
Neanderthals extinct. I think for me I
have no heard an answer I believe 100%.
Maybe it's a mixture of different things.
- Very nice. We're going to do another one
now for Brenna, and then perhaps it will
be time to switch over to the second group
of speakers. This goes to Brenna. “We see
a strong drive in humans to spread
throughout the world and interact in some
way with archaic species, but there seems
to be very little back flow into Africa as
evidence by a lack of
Neanderthal/Denisovan DNA in African
genome. What factors may have prevented
back flow of genes into Africa?”
- That's a complex question. There
actually was a recent paper arguing that
there was gene flow back to Africa,
specifically into northeastern Africa and
Ethiopia using an ancient genome. That
paper is now somewhat controversial due to
some biostatistical mistakes. I actually,
a few years ago, looked at gene flow from
the east into north Africa and one of the
things that we did see in that paper, is
that there likely was an event back to
Africa approximately 30,000 years ago, or
30 to 40,000 years ago. So I would say
it's not a closed junction. I think there
have been periods in time that are
probably climatically influenced, in which
populations did move back and forth
between the near east and northeastern
Africa. But Africa is a highly complex
environmental area, so if you think about
adaptation to local environment, for
example, malaria is really prevalent in
some areas of central and eastern and
western Africa, and you're going to have a
hard time surviving there if you don't
carry alleles that allow you to be not
susceptible to malaria, for example. So I
thinks it's probably a combination of both
environment and local adaptation to some
pathogens that have probably influenced
relatively low levels of back to Africa
migration.
- All right, I said that was the last one,
but I'm going to take the organizer's
prerogative and ask Matthias Meyer one
more question. So the dating for the split
between what would become modern humans
and what would become Neanderthals and
Denisovans, with the Sima de los Huesos
sample, this has been pushed back in time.
But we thought we had a a reasonably good
answer for that with wide error bars, and
that was up to something like 400,000
years ago. Now, you've shown this was more
distant in the past. The first estimate
was based on comparing alleles that we
share with Neanderthals. How often can we
expect to see this in a modern human
population? So how old are these things?
How long ago in the past they must have
split? But now we know somehow that must
have been, there must have been something
wrong with that. Where does the discord
come from, and is there a chance that we
find yet another archaic hominid that can
cause us to revisit this yet again? Is
this the final answer on the split between
human and things that we are most closely
related to but they're extinct? And don't
say good question.
- I mean, in principle, there is some
uncertainty there, of course, with the
dating of the Sima site, also. I mean its
genetic evidence and geological evidence
seem to sort of converge with confidence
towards a very large also in this case.
But to give a good answer to this rather
detailed question, I think Kay might be a
better person to do that. As the genetic
estimates of populations splits, were
actually sort of described in the Altai
Neanderthal paper that he first authored,
so I think he has a chance to explain it
in better detail.
- So I think Christina might also be in on
this question. Okay so, essentially
there's one big thing, one kind of very
basic problem in any study of evolutionary
questions that have to do with time and
that is the mutation rate. It is actually
massively surprising that it took us so
long to kind of come to or halfway to a
conclusion of what this number should be.
So then, one of the reasons for this, is
that it's actually quite hard to measure.
So until now, we didn't have the
opportunity to sequence entire
genomes...or just recently we actually
came around to do it. And so when we
started doing this with humans, as modern
humans, just parents and offspring, we
started seeing there are actually only few
differences between parent and offspring
and the mutation rate that we always
assumed would be true actually doesn't
really fit very well. And so with less
mutations that you see from generation to
generation, that actually appears that
events that we just measure by the number
of mutations that happen in a certain
amount of time are actually further back
in the past. And I think this switch of
understanding mutations rate better
explains this discordance between these
two initial estimates and the later
estimates.
- Was that praise for the answer?
Fantastic. Good job guys. We'll now switch
to the second half.
- First off, we will put Josh on the spot.
Where's Josh? Okay, I have a couple
questions for you. “What evidence supports
presence of Neanderthal genes in human
populations due to admixture as opposed to
DNA coming from an ancestor to both?”
- [Josh] Am I allowed to say good
question? It's a fantastic question,
actually, because it's one of the most
difficult things in these types of
inferences is distinguishing sequences
that were inherited from admixture versus
being shared from a common ancestor. The
approach that we're using really relies on
finding Neanderthal sequences based on
both divergence and how long those
sequences are. And so, if was just a
common ancestor so incomplete lineage
sorting, you would expect the chunks to be
much smaller in size compared to what
we're detecting. But it does complicate
the inference and that's something that
you have to be really careful about.
- “In the hybridization of archaic and
modern humans, was it male moderns and
female Neanderthals or vice versa or
both?”
- I'll paraphrase the question. So was
there a sex bias in hybridization? And I
think it's a fascinating question that
we've thought a lot about but haven't come
up with a way to distinguish sort of if
there was a bias, and if there was, in
what direction. In fact, we know that
there's sex bias gene flow that has
happened in different modern human
populations, so it wouldn't be surprising,
I think, if that was the case. But the
approaches that we use to study sex bias
migration in modern human populations,
doesn't really work well in applying it to
the interaction between modern and archaic
populations. I think it's a great
question. We don't know the answer yet. I
think it's something that hopefully a lot
of people are thinking about because it's
a complicated question but one that I
think is worth figuring out how to answer.
- “According to my National Geographic
report, I'm smack in the average for
Neanderthal at 2%, but I also have 2.6
Denisovan. I'm of basically European
ancestry. How did I get so much Denisovan
considering my background?”
- This is also a good question and
actually I don't know why, but I've
received about 10 emails in the last
couple days asking this exact question.
I'm going to probably get myself in
trouble. This is being recorded, so
National Geographic is going to sue me.
But those estimates are just wrong. In
fact, if you look at the genochip
frequently asked questions page, at some
point they admitted that the Denisovan
estimates were wrong, too. So I think it's
a complicated sort of question to try to
tease apart sequences that you're
confident is Neanderthal versus confident
they were Denisovan and sometimes you can
actually tell the difference. I suspect
that sort of, the higher percentage of
Denisovan ancestry estimated by the
National Geographic project was just cases
of them sort of overestimating the
Denisovan contribution. Maybe over time,
they can do a better job, but I would be
suspicious of what your ancestry estimates
are, at least from Denisovan right now.
And if you would like to donate to my
legal fund, maybe we can post a website
later.
- I'm of course, just pleased that my
husband's percentage is higher. Okay,
Tony. Where are you? There you are. All
right, “I heard a great deal about
Neanderthal DNA in European genomes, but
has there been any contribution or
variation in mitochondrial DNA?” A number
of you could answer this but they put your
name down.
- [Tony] So I'll start first with the
context of the sorts of things I talked
about and no, we haven't really looked at
that at all. One of the big reasons is
because the initial studies that tried to
decide if there was admixture were focused
on mitochondrial DNA for reasons that have
come up in some of the earlier talks and
found very limited evidence, in fact no
evidence of that in those mitochondrial
sequences. There really wouldn't be a
clear signature of what would be
intergressed there or not. It's not really
possible to look at that.
- “Is there an ongoing effort, on the part
of scientists to encourage the expansion
of genomic information for medical data or
from these large medical organizations
like Scripts and UCSD?” A number of people
asked why there weren't any dots on your
map in the West?
- Yes, there was one in University of
Washington that's a partner in this
network that we used. There are similar
efforts that are coming up on the West
coast. For example Kaiser, has a large
database that has some similar attributes
to what we have and have been looking at
that they're building. This is a wide, as
I showed across a lot of the world,
countries and individual hospital systems
are really really excited about the
potential of electronic medical record
data linked to genetic data for the
purposes of precision or personalized
medicine as you've heard. So there's
great, great interest. You might also have
heard, several months ago, there's the
precision medicine initiative announced by
the President. It's a nationwide effort to
get millions of people across the country
to get involved in systems like this.
That's great from the perspective of
understanding the genetics of disease. But
from my perspective it's also great about
trying to understand the evolution of our
species and how that relates to our risk
for disease.
- Okay, Johannes, “Since you're German, is
it Neandertal or Neanderthal?”
- [Johannes] Wow. Wrong question, I should
refer to Kay or Matthias for that again. I
actually came from the Leipzig School
myself as well, and there we call it “tal”
not "thal," which goes back to some
phonetic change that actually happened
about 100 years ago in Germany where we
now call a valley "tals" it was "t".
Whereas 150 years ago, when the Neandertal
was discovered in the Neander Valley, it
was still with "th." So therefore, I think
we have changed our language and we
therefore adopted also the "t" and not the
"th" but I know it's under discussion and
debate so....
- Our linguistics for today. Okay, “Is the
second migration related to the spread of
Indo-European language and what
contribution to do you think warfare
played in some of these large scale
genetic migrations?”
- In the paper that we published last
year, we actually hypothesized that the
second migration was also related to
spread of the Indo-European languages and
I think there is more and more evidence
actually popping up that this is actually
true. I'm working in the institute now. I
was one of the leading linguists that
actually has done divergence estimates of
ancient language with [inaudible
00:29:30], and they have actually dated
that the early divergence of Indo-European
languages was something like 8,000 years
ago, which is actually younger than the
separation of Anatolian populations from
basically the near east to Europe. It
really seems to better actually relate to
this split that might have happened 6 to
7,000 years ago maybe in the steppe. I
think there is actually very good evidence
for that, also there is more evidence
coming to light soon on the genetic makeup
of early farmers in the near east and I
think that will also be interesting to
look at that. But from my point of view, I
think there is very good evidence for
that. But of course, it's very difficult
to link genes and language, because of
course, those ancient skeletons and DNA
doesn't really tell us what those people
were speaking. But I think there's
actually a good case for that. What was
the second question? Warfare, yes. The
people that actually spread during the
time, this corded ware culture, is
actually also called the battle axe
culture. So much for that question. I
think there's very strong evidence that
those people have actually been quite
violent. There almost all of them are
buried with axes, which were probably not
just used to chop wood, but maybe also
heads. So I think there is actually some
evidence for that. How strong that
evidence is, and if that would explain the
complete turnover is quite uncertain, but
it also might have been related to that.
Again, we don't really know whether it was
diseases, whether it was some other
changes in the environment or really
warfare that have actually caused this
genetic turnover. It's a good question.
- So there were a couple questions
basically asking, "We have this really
rich detailed record in Europe. Why don't
we have it anywhere else?"
- I think as Anne said, we are getting
there. So I think Maria has shown that
more and more genetic information from the
Americas. I think there's also a lot of
ancient genomes coming to light in the
next few years in the Americas, even for
Africa, we have seen the first ancient
genomes now from Africa. They're only
about 4,000 years old, but still they have
actually given us first controversial
results as we heard, but also I think some
very exciting and interesting insight. So
I think we are getting material now from
Africa, the Americas, also probably from
Australia, and Oceania. I think we will
actually learn more about those different
parts of the world that we know so much
about Europe is also because there's been
a lot of archaeology and paleoanthropology
done in Europe, so therefore we have
probably many more skeletons that have
been excavated in Europe. But I think
we're soon catching up also in other parts
of the world, which is an extremely
exciting time. Because unlike people that
are working on archaic humans, we're not
just dealing with 300 fossils. We are
actually dealing with millions of fossils
that basically can be actually studied
genetically. We will learn a tremendous
amount about human history studying those
millions of fossils over the next few
years, which is a really exciting time and
really glad to be a part of that.
- Let's see, “How fast,” in miles per
year, I guess, “do you think ancient
people would have migrated since they've
got 8,000 plus miles to get all the way
down to Chile to Monte Verde? Does 1,000
years seem likely?
- [Maria] I think in kilometers, not in
miles. But actually 1,000 years is like an
estimate now, for the time that it took
people to move all the way from Alaska to
Monte Verde. So that's an estimate now. I
don't know how many miles or kilometers
that is.
- “Is there some evidence for migration
into the Americas around 30,000 years BP?”
There's some questions, I guess, about
some bones in caves in Brazil.
- That's still very controversial. I
didn't want to bring it up because it's
very debatable. So there is evidence in
Brazil, of something that looks like stone
tools that could have been made by humans.
But it also, like some people argue,
that's just the shape of a rock falling
from somewhere that is somewhere high. So
yeah. It's inconclusive.
- The last question, “Could the shared
skull morphology among Austronesians and
South Americans be a result of shared
Denisovan or Denisovan-like ancestry?”
- I don't know. Actually, what we know
about skull morphology, is that it's
highly variable and that there is many
environmental factors that weigh in. What
we actually think is happening here is
some sort of adaptation at least in the
Pericose and the Fuego-Patagonians. I had
that question myself as well. Maybe the
signal that we see in South America, could
be something of shared Denisovan ancestry
because it's been observed also. But in
these particular groups [inaudible
00:35:17] there's also high Denisovan
ancestry there. So I don't know if that
could be a contender.
- [Ajit] On behalf of CARTA, I'd like to
thank all those that made this symposium
possible. To the chairs, featured
speakers, the supporters, and to the
audience attending and your great
questions. We forgot to specifically thank
Judd Svabota [SP] for playing the guitar
so well at the beginning. And the person
who made this slide always leaves his name
off, Jesse Robbe did the artwork. So I
would like to leave you with a closing
question to ponder. “Why are there no
persisting true hybrid species of us
humans, with Denisovans, Neanderthals, or
anyone else?” In other words, what
happened to everyone else? So Svante Paabo
was visiting here a month or two ago, and
he and I had a chat. He came up with a
possible answer. The answer is that humans
are the most dominate, expansive,
ecologically invasive, aggressive, and
destructive species this planet has ever
experienced. And that took care of
everybody else. And so we needn't to
understand our species of course. Thank
you.
♪ [music] ♪